[Applause]
you guys are making it red carpet
official we're all ready together
[Music]
yo asap did you let me stand under your
umbrella tonight
real friends laugh at corny jokes
you're working on that all week and when
it's rihanna they walk right over and
ask you about your upcoming wedding
is national school update
it's happening yes
riri's billowing valenciaga gown is
fresh off the runway in july asap stuck
to the american theme and wrapped
himself in what looked like a quilt it
represents america
i hear you having right party of all
parties tonight i i got to work in the
morning for that after party brianna
ditched the coat and went super casual
and was spotted leaving with asap
fellow fashion queen j lo arrived solo
where's ben
but not to worry ben met her inside
where they shared a kiss with their mask
on jyn rocked a western look from ralph
lauren here's the original sketch 15
embroidery specialists worked on the
dress for 12 days did you come up with a
look this evening
was it a collaborative effort
next show stopper kim k and custom
balenciaga covered from head to toe in
black she inspired a ton of memes
including comparisons to harry potter
dementors and when you finally step out
of your sister's shadow today kim shared
some behind-the-scenes photos and
addressed the night's theme quote what's
more american than a t-shirt head to toe
a source tells e.t kim's little sister
kylie was considering a gender reveal at
the met gala but changed her mind are
you excited about the new baby yeah
from kim and all black to little nazex
dripping in gold after the vmas
am i going to see at the mat gala
tomorrow night we finally gave y'all
something yep nas came through serving
up not one not two but three outfits a
regal cloak shimmery gold jumpsuit and
this custom molded golden armor which of
course brought on the force of c-3po
memes
another star who made a statement newly
engaged kate hudson i really want to see
this bling kate
so beautiful
kate showed off the stunning yellow
square diamond ring as she got from
boyfriend of nearly five years danny
fujikawa her date was her go-to met gala
plus one michael kors who designed this
pink matching floor-length feather coat
bralette and skirt with 80 000 sequins
it took 4 000 hours to make other stars
going solo
i'm hungry uh not gonna lie gabrielle
union starving and perfectly shading
hubby dwyane wade where's play he
decided to watch the bears game instead
shocking too bad
gabby was white hot covered in thousands
of circles this took 1400 hours to make
what's the first thing you want to eat
when you get out of here girlfriend
thanks edie um it's real specific
obviously i'm ripping my husband's
jersey tonight and i'm also wearing my
husband's super bowl wing which is
pretty cool
be careful with that oh yes sierra is
also protective of her honorary niece
hitting the met for the first time kobe
bryant's daughter model natalia bryant
listen nani is a star
she knows what she's doing i'm so
excited and so nervous at the same time
having my whole family like support me
is just so it's just so nice and i
that's just everything
[Music]
megan fox was without her valentine on
the carpet going blood red for her met
debut in the strappy don discount but
she quick changed it to a shorter red
number meeting mgk at bieber's after
party another couple who walk solo but
hooked up later who are you wearing
tonight channing tatum
versace hey where's your lady channing
tatum and zoe kravitz left their hotel
together but post separately two hours
apart what are you most looking forward
to this evening zoey setting up these
stairs now falling down
we're told the pair of about a month was
seen inside holding hands he also pulled
her chair out for her they had a long
night scene at 6 a.m today after
partying with tessa thompson
[Applause]
but there were lots of couples walking
the beige carpet together justin and
haley held hands and turned the night
into their own anniversary party
celebrating three years of wedded bliss
i'm married now so i think things just
become more
adult i guess
once inside justin messed up and
performed a throwback of his hit baby
there were no awkward run-ins with an x
for haley she was at the gala in 2018
with then-boyfriend shawn mendes just
four months before she said i do to
justin
this time shawn showed up bear chested
with girlfriend camila caveo who made
her met debut in a stunning purple
michael kors ensemble
other first time couples at the mets
rita ora and taikaweti teach
i'm her date yeah you know and i just
really i mean want to do something chic
and nice and actually just compliments
what she's doing also coordinating kit
harrington and rose leslie who went with
an old hollywood look as brits i think
there's this real
love of everything 1950s america
hollywood
i'll give you guys before and then i'm
gonna let you
oh my god but then you gotta see what my
wife is doing
some couples made an appearance night
out like chance the rapper and wife
kirsten corley who left daughters marley
and kinsley at home it's cool to be
around people first of all but it's also
cool to be around cool people
it's always fun night away from the kids
we got a babysitter do you know what i
mean like
it's a free dinner you know
[Applause]
what was the most difficult aspect of
your outfit to put on this evening jade
mostly the spanx it's the spanx
underneath they're just rolled out of
spanx now to the inspiration behind some
of the biggest fashion statements
starting with co-chair billy eilish's
stunning oscar de lorenzo gown diamonds
are girl's best friend
you are giving me marilyn monroe vibes
young lady is that what you were going
for this little way
meanwhile kendall jenner channeled
another old hollywood star
her custom givenchy dress was an homage
to audrey hepburn's glam gown and my
fair lady
hot mama gigi adid was giving major
jessica rabbit vibes with a long red
pony black gloves and strapless product
that was at times a little tough to get
up the stairs in
it's not the moment without having a
little trip it's better it happens like
quickly
tracy ellis ross's valenciaga was
inspired by her own mother diana ross's
character in the 1975 film mahogany
taraji p henson couldn't choose just one
legend to inspire her disco themed
mosquito jumpsuit oh to diana ross
because i love her donna summers you
know i i'm that girl
dan levy's global look featuring two men
kissing was described as quote what a
gay superhero might wear
oh 76 year old brock pioneer debbie
harry sure answered the call for the
night's theme american independence
herzeg posen was a literal american flag
and co-chair amanda gorman and lord help
set the tone for another patriotic theme
tonight i am a re-imagined statue of
liberty and while emily blunt also looks
at you asking her custom mew-mew her
look was actually inspired by old
hollywood actress hedy lamarr's
character in the 1941 film zigfeld girl
old hollywood well honey with a crown